She's been waiting half an hour, what took you so long?
I'm in a hurry, my back is killing me, can we just do this?
I just got a collection notice from you people.
If this affects my credit, I will sue!
Do you feel as though your job becomes more demanding and stressful every day?
For most of us, there's just too much to do...
...and not enough time to get it done.
With pressures like these,...
...it can be all too easy to forget about the needs of the person we're here to help:...
...the patient.
The result: patient dissatisfaction, patient complaints,...
...and even more job stress for you.
Today more than ever, it's important we learn how to handle patient complaints easily and quickly.
What we need is a simple, easy-to-remember formula for managing patient complaints:...
...STAT.